zack snyder's justice league is
everything fans who have been asking for
the snyder cut for the last few years
could have hoped for
it has a much darker tone than the 2017
version
culminating in superman donning his
iconic black suit
we actually get a chance to see darkseid
as opposed to merely hearing steppenwolf
mention him
and best of all we get a better look at
the nightmare reality that was first
introduced in batman vs superman dawn of
justice
snyder took it even further actually
going so far as to film an additional
scene for his cut that showcased another
nightmare sequence in which batman has a
philosophical conversation with the
joker about the destruction they caused
before the timeline was ruined by
darkseid we may not get a chance to see
the two comic book titans fight or
potentially even work together but jared
leto left his mark on his version of the
character with one noteworthy line that
broke the internet when the justice
league trailer came out
the whole idea behind the snyder cut is
that it's something brought to fruition
for the fans
they've been asking to see a movie
closer to snyder's original vision for
years and now that it's actually
available on hbo max it only makes sense
for the film to give those fans a little
something extra
as if seeing jared leto's joker one more
time to actually have a conversation
with batman wasn't enough
there's some bonus fan service during
the trailer for zack snyder's justice
league when the character says
we live in a society for those of you
who don't go on social media all that
often the phrase we live in a society
became a meme that gained prevalence
around the time of 2019's joker the
origin of the phrase can be traced back
all the way to seinfeld where george
exclaimed
you know we're living in a society
but over the years it's been associated
with the joker both in earnest and
satirical manners to talk about
perceived slights in the larger culture
that are enough to radicalize people
into becoming joker-esque in an effort
as it would seem to tap
into the zeitgeist and considering
snyder filmed justice league's nightmare
scene in 2020
it was easy enough for leto to slip it
in in an interview with the hollywood
reporter snyder mentions how he wrote a
script for the scene
after getting some ideas for what he
wanted out of these versions of batman
and the joker but the director does
reveal we went back and forth with it
and i'll give jared leto credit for that
little ad-lib there
hype was already through the roof for
the snyder cup but that line in the
trailer just confirmed that this movie
was for
all of the comic book fans almost as a
way to reward them for being so vocal
online
but some are still displeased while the
line is fun for fans it doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense in context
these characters are living in a
post-apocalyptic hellscape ruled over by
one of dc's new gods
what society is there to be found with
political and bureaucratic functions
as it turns out anyone who watched the
full four hours of the movie hoping to
hear the meme was sadly disappointed
when the joker didn't actually say it
as with every minor inconvenience in
life people took to twitter to voice
their displeasure at being duped
one twitter user wrote i'm shocked
shocked that joker doesn't actually say
we live in a society and justice league
the deception has even turned into a
meme in its own right with another user
writing
i haven't watched justice league but
snyder having joker say we live in a
society in the trailer and then making
people sit through a four hour movie
only to realize joker never actually
says it was pure genius
to all of this we suppose you could say
we live in a society in which trailers
tell you one thing but the movie gives
you another
even without the line in the movie there
was still plenty for fans to satisfy
their appetites for superhero action
and while this is likely the last time
we'll get to see jared leto with green
hair and white makeup or
at least doing so as the dceu character
he at least gave us one final scene to
close out his run as the joker
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite dc movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one